tomorrow's president rumps 100th day in
office in our ongoing series weeded
people we go beyond the polls and
pundits to explore voters optimism and
their frustration we followed up with
four people of varying political
backgrounds and beliefs we asked them to
write letters to the president for this
symbolic bit benchmark dear President
Trump my name is Stephen shook my name
is Cesar Vargas I'm Leo Smith dear mr.
president my name is holly mansions cook
I'm a 26 year old resident of Struthers
Ohio and I did not vote for you in the
election I grew up in a small
blue-collar community most of whom you
appeal to in your campaign even though I
wasn't drawn into your rhetoric I would
like to ask on behalf of all those who
were why haven't any of your political
promises been fulfilled in your first
100 days as president I'm a businessman
and an activist with the Georgia
Republican Party and I voted for you I
Donald John Trump do solemnly swear
I still believe at the top of my list
during the 2016 election was the need
for a candidate who would disrupt the
status quo
[Music]
judging by the number of political
pundits and foreign heads of state
complaining about your lack of
predictability and you're calling from
Twitter feed I say we woke people up
dealing with global issues in Syria
North Korea and Afghanistan you have
used and shown necessary force and in
doing so you have shown the world that
the United States now has a real
commander in chief I completely agree
with the action that you took to show
the Syrian government but the United
States will not sit idly by while they
torture and kill innocent people it does
make a person wonder though if you truly
cared about the suffering of Syrian
children why have you banned them from
the safety of our country their
president Trump I'm an attorney from
standout New York and if I could vote I
will not vote for you you say you had a
great heart and you wouldn't deport
dreamers like me and yet the nation is
seeing the rise of a deportation force
that's creating a climate of fear and
deporting dreamers and good people you
have deported criminals who are living
here illegally again you have shown our
country in the world that America and
our safety come first I have children
tell me they are afraid to go to school
even some us-born Latinos in my
community feel they now have to carry
their American passport just in case
they come in contact with immigration
pre Trump my 9 year old son Luke had an
experiment life vision but his vision
was only matched by his occasional
distress about the state of his future
as an American your attention is needed
in addressing schools where
english-speaking students have subject
time curtailed by the reality that many
of their classmates cannot understand
classes taught in English we do embrace
legal immigration but not at the expense
of academic progress as an educator I am
very concerned about your appointment of
Betsy DeVos as Secretary of Education I
was just asking to clarify as a teacher
in a low-income district I am very
worried that free and reduced school
lunches may be cut
seen students digging through trash cans
looking for something to eat when not in
school my only disappointment in your
first 100 days of your presidency was
the proposed health care reform we're
going to be living with Obamacare for
the first evil future as a young
entrepreneur and as someone who has
specialized healthcare needs due to
undergoing brain surgery eight years ago
the current cost of health care is
extremely unaffordable for myself and
for many other Americans being the
president is about trust with all your
proven lies how can you expect to be
trusted
[Music]
you get an A for stimulating market
confidence sir but we need lowering
middle-class jobs I know that you have
faced a tremendous amount of opposition
from people and by media outlets my
advice to you for whatever it's worth
stay humble mr. president even in the
face of opposition I want you to succeed
but only if you bring out the best of
this nation not the worst I hope that at
the end of your four years I can be
proud of what you achieved and work
towards your first 100 days has been in
reshaping of American vision and we
thank you for it we're now more
interested in the engine of the car and
not the flamboyance of the driver so sir
please just deliver the pizza Americans
are hungry it's really good what's
really good about it it shows you the
eloquent people yeah there you can tell
they put a lot of thought into and what
I like is it's such a good cross-section
of people that we're talking to - yeah
there's something there well done
writing down your thoughts before you
speak them yeah that adds to a
thoughtfulness yeah it's a good idea it
is right thank before you speak
yeah right I mean if that's unusual I
haven't seen a piece done like that what
we're doing is very original very much
that's very CBS this morning Nora I like
Al King I like that
and we're gonna follow up with Leo
Hallie and Caesar and Stephen to see how
their perspectives might change
throughout the Trump presidency